[Music]
jason is with us in phoenix hi jason
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey chrissy thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
so um me and my spouse we make a
combined
income of uh almost four hundred
thousand a year
wow and uh i started listening yeah
we're
incredibly blessed and we started
listening our show about a year ago
and we've been cranking away on debt but
i i gotta admit i haven't been
completely following the steps
we have been continuing to completely
fund
our 401k uh during baby step two
and my question is because of deferring
taxes
should we continue to completely fund
our 401ks
or should we shut that off until we
finish out this last
105 000 in debt
how quickly are you going to finish um
a year and a half okay if not sooner
well i tell people to stop their
retirement temporarily
so what's that going to cost you a year
and a half of investing
um and which is certainly not the end of
the world it's not gonna mean that you
are bankrupt it's not gonna mean
and if you don't follow our guidance
and keep doing what you're doing are you
still gonna win yeah you'll still win
that's a year and a half if you're
funding the 401k it's a year if you
don't
right correct you should pay off a
hundred thousand a year making 400
really
i mean really that leaves you 300 to
struggle through on
barely squeezing out
what kind of debt is it um it's uh
one vehicle one rv and a
uh homework home equity loan okay
yeah the point is that um
the reason you're
you're going to be fine either way and
you kind of know that before you asked
right
the reason we tell people to stop even
though it is mathematically incorrect to
temporarily stop
their retirement savings even if there's
a match while they get out of debt
is simply this personal finance is 80
behavior it's 20 head knowledge and the
power of
focus supersedes short-term mathematical
gains
and so getting this done
and leaning in with a singular focus
and a growl in your voice when you write
down your budget each month
ah you know that is actually
10 years from today will have made you
more money than what than this one year
of investing would have made you
and so that's the argument and that's
why we tell people to do it
uh because doing three things at once
causes you to get
nothing done now in your case you've got
so stinking much
wood that you can throw on this fire
that the fire's gonna keep burning
anyway you're gonna make it because my
god you just make so much money i mean
you're overwhelming the question with
your income
you know gotcha
and i mean in other words you can get
away with you can get away with screwing
this up
and still come out you're gonna be okay
either way the thing is jason is it's up
to you how long
you want this to last because if you
want to be out of debt
in a year stop your retirement if you
want to be out of debt sooner put more
than
whatever you're putting on it you take
the money you're putting in retirement
put that towards your debt
maybe you live on less for a shorter
amount of time
you could be out of debt even faster
it's up to you how quickly do you want
to be out of debt
here's the here's the only in your
situation
it's a harder argument to make is what
i'm saying but
still philosophically and conceptually
what we teach teaching people to stop
stands in your case maybe there's one
other argument
because you're obviously high
performance people
and uh me too so
i sometimes will engage in
a behavior that is not necessary for me
to win because i want new grooves in my
brain
i want the old sewage washed out
and so this is like breakthrough
behavior
you know you're shifting your behaviors
you're shifting your habits
and it kind of pisses you off that you
have to stop this
and it's like this makes me never go
into debt again
and if i kind of play around and wallow
out
i i didn't get the groove in my brain i
didn't get the crap washed off my brain
from the bad way of doing it this is
this is like a cleansing
a reset yeah uh uh you know it's the
cold
shower thing you know yeah uh the the
the the what are they calling the
cooling pool when you jump into the car
ah you know it shocks the system and
resets
and for high performance people that's
necessary
well and it's the people that stand on
this debt-free stage that tell their
story is this
visceral never going back
because of the sacrifice they had to go
through to get to that point
and if you don't have that sacrifice if
you don't have some type of man this is
uncomfortable and hard and i'm
a little mad about it then you may go
back that's a good point you may go back
you're like i won that hard let's do it
again i don't think he's going to go
back but
what i'm saying is it just retrains you
it's like
the the groove my my habit my my
behaviors are
permanently shifted yeah because i
forced myself through some discomfort
right yeah that that's a high
performance activity people that are
high performance do that kind of thing
so that that's um i catch myself doing
that in all kinds of different areas of
my life i'm like
okay i gotta break that in order to
break that i gotta go over here
and like i gotta create an uncomfortable
thing so that never go back over there
yeah
you know and that kind of a deal so
that's kind of where i would throw this
to but
either way dude you're gonna be just
fine you keep cranking that guy if you
do either one of these two plans
mathematically you're gonna be fine but
that's the argument
for stopping your retirement temporarily
while you're in baby step two and the
rest of you don't even call me ask that
question because i'll just tell you
don't do it
i'm not gonna give you as much grace i
gave him because you're not making 400
grand
all right